[Music]
so you're talking Pikachu with no
memories he's addicted to check-in this
is what a Frenchman would call Caliente
fiesta operation this magic that brought
us together
and that magic is called hope we're
gonna do this use your body words we're
nuts of the games say it just say it so
c'mon detective Pikachu only in theaters
May 10
[Music]
[Music]
bring me the land
your life begins now
[Music]
Aladin
[Music]
you really don't know who I am genie
wishes land none today I ring it about
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
call and text every day
Mohamed's college it's not a survival
course it'll be fine there okay are you
a virgin I'll do dare I dare you to make
out with her I'm done playing this game
oh I like this girl
deep question who is hard and Scott I
think that it's better if we keep our
distance welcome to my favorite place
[Music]
thought that you just wanted to runs I
think we can never be just friends cuz I
just can't stop thinking about you
you are stunning
nothing could ever change the way that I
feel about you just be careful what
happened it has to do with hard
something's going on it's not what
you've been making a big mistake he's
got a great job
why are you dreaming about
[Music]
great for this
[Music]
so how do you think we did think we're
missing just one thing
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Patricia I'm very sorry about your loss
I can't even imagine how you must feel
your children lifting Lutze are safe now
I thought they heard her crying they
felt this thing of reduce
they will
if you will come for the
I don't know the church works with
people who specialize in the situation's
language gets a lot your honor
is she coming she's all right here
we are facing an evil
it has no bells the curse of La Llorona
[Music]
tell me a story
it's a story about journeys the journeys
we take to prove ourselves
it's about conventions it's about potent
magic magic beyond anything anyone has
ever [ __ ] before but what it means
tough and to be loved up courage
it's about fellowship
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why did you enter this competition
noticing a lot of people like to sing
you can nursing but you're an
inexperienced performer with a Polish
name entering a competition that relies
on the public vote never dreamed I would
make it this far
[Music]
seems from here
see how he's doing he's not a real
manager
or anything but he has a lot for me we
can do a lot more you can do this violet
you can do this
sing from your heart I had a way
[Music]
we would like to offer violet a contract
but you have to sign before the shower
it's a no-go
that's the deal the dark
[Music]
why me you're a caterpillar we're a
cocoon maybe together we make a
butterfly
[Music]